Alright, well thank you all for being here,
handling the weather as well as this other distractions,
which we will catch later on.
So let me pray for us as we get started.
Rather be with us tonight as we just continue to try to
learn more from, uh, the instruction that you left us about
how to treat each other, how to treat other people, how
to treat our spouses, um,
and just so that we will experience as much of the joy
that you designed us for as possible.
And, um, thank you for everybody being here tonight
and just the, uh, keep us all safe that we're
having weather tonight.
So we thank you in Jesus' name. Amen.
Alright, so, um, tonight
we are going to, as I've got up here on the board,
and if you, if you saw the, if you were at the
workshop we did, this will, without question go over some
of the same material, but I have always believed repetition
was not a bad thing.
It's kinda like if you heard it the first time
and it sounded interesting
and it was maybe useful, that's great.
But most of us don't change habits that quickly.
You know, we don't hear something once
and then it just totally floods our life in a way
that we never act in old ways again.
So I think
We can attest to that After.
Yeah. Are you gonna throw me under the bus again?
30 years of doing this material,
we still bump into stuff. That's
Oh, yeah.
Yeah. And if you think you have it down,
then God takes you into a new season of life
and changes things.
Uh, Jimmy just sent us a message about the iPad.
So sorry, Jimmy, I got that on the recording,
but, uh, anyway, I'm not sure what it was,
but I think he was just saying we,
we put one in there.
So, um, I'm gonna do a quick reference to last week,
that focus last week, hello focus last week was how
we are truly designed sovereignly by God,
such that when we come into this world, we created
to connect, we're looking for someone who loves us,
and that includes who, who delights in us.
And if we don't have that,
and yet our brain was pre-wired, hardwired to expect that,
then we're gonna have to adjust how we deal with life,
every little bit of it.
And yet, we didn't come into this world with, uh, education
and with all that knowledge we came in without any
education, without the use of words.
So we're, we're searching in the dark
for what's this supposed to look like
and what we are designed for was good
and created by God.
And that would be a family system where there's a mom
and a dad and they each bring not only two
different genders, they bring two different personalities.
And yet, if they were living totally in obedience to God,
they're giving us what we need every single day.
Garden of Eden, before the fall, just,
Ima use your imagination.
We'd all be acting right, thinking right, responding right.
And that means those little kids would get all
of the attention that they need and they'd be valued
and comforted and, uh, it'd all be good.
But I failed at that. I'm sorry,
I failed at that. Well,
once you say what, what you mean by that?
I didn't do all those things with you.
Oh, with our son? Yeah. Okay.
I was picturing you as a little baby there for a second.
Okay. Yeah. Nor did I far from it.
Uh, he was in eighth grade from when we were introduced
to these principals.
Mm-Hmm. And
I just failed at it.
And I had to go, go back to him
and ask for his apology or an apology.
Yeah. I think he cuts you
more slack than he did me.
That's another story. But, uh, I, I, so
one thing we find a lot is when we're teaching these
principles for marriages, oftentimes people
who are in the room already have kids
who have grown quite a bit, or they're even adult kids.
And sometimes they'll actually start kind
of beating themselves up.
Oh my gosh, what have we done?
We didn't do any stuff like this.
And we just reassure them that it never is too late
to start making improvements in how we relate to people.
It's never too late. That doesn't mean they'll
respond the way we would hope they would.
It just says we're all in a process of sanctification.
This is just one of many areas.
So just want to kind of normalize that a little bit.
So join the club and we are too.
So we talked about, um, how we were,
we were, uh, created to connect.
And one of the ways that we connect is we,
um, connect on an emotional level,
not just an intellectual level.
Um, which looks like
if I tell you something that happened to me,
you don't just absorb the factual information
without any movement in your heart.
If I share something good with you, you respond
with some kind of rejoicing with me.
If I share something negative with you
or a sad thing with you, then you respond on that level.
You meet me where I'm at.
And I think last week I mentioned a verse, Romans 1215,
very simple verse, very short verse,
but a verse that's basically covering both of those bases.
It says, rejoice with those who rejoice
and mourn with those who mourn.
So we're gonna practice that here for just a few seconds.
Um, Brandon, if your, if your wife is not here,
you get to share with Joyce.
Yes. Would that be okay? Yes. You good with that? Yes, sir.
Okay. So rejoice with those who rejoice
would be, I'm excited for you.
That sounds really good. I'm glad that happened for you.
Um, mourn with those who, tell me more and tell me more.
Yeah. And mourn with those
who mourn would be, that sounds hard.
That sounds bad. Sorry that happened to you.
Instead of pep talks changing the
subject, that kind of thing.
So I want you to practice Romans 1215
for just a couple of minutes here.
Okay. Such that maybe, uh, Bernie,
you would share something good that happened to you
this week with Angie and she would rejoice with you.
Now if we start seeing the two of you jumping up
and doing high fives, that's okay.
That'll be okay. If we're teaching this to teenagers,
that's the way it happens.
Okay. They get into it, um,
except when they're embarrassed to get into it.
But that's another thing. Um, and,
and then you invite her to share what's something good
to happen to you this week and do the same thing.
And then let's go ahead and do the second part also.
What was something that was difficult for you this week?
Now, I, I'm actually suggesting this is not the time
to bring up a argument between you or something like that.
Stick with stuff that's external
to your relationship for today.
We'll get to that stuff in about week six
or five, somewhere in there.
Okay. So go ahead and take turns.
She, and I'll give you a little warning
before we, we sharing something good,
Something Positive, something good.
And then after you each share something good, then, uh, say,
well, tell me something that was difficult for you this week
or left you sad, or something like that.
Okay.
Okay. How about you? Pretty, she has,
She has to share all songs.
I thought we just said. Okay.
So just making, making sure
you first
Rejoice wise, Uh,
I got an opportunity to Referee
Basketball game.
It was, uh, it was actually a bucket.
I said it was actually a bucket.
So to get the train out.
Oh great. So my daughter used to play,
but she currently plays volley.
Uh, The basketball referee
Training route Was a precursor to try to get into the
Basketball training.
And so that's good for you.
I did actually, I did five training, got a certification.
So after the certification,
It was exciting. You did
it after five.
I had to, I traveled before
and so my daughter was not feeling the best
on the day that I had to leave.
And it's always joke,
but it's kind of like seeing the reason why I go is
to make sure, you know,
they like leave
Was Kind like she was already down.
I work for a medical device.
Like When a physician buys I technology,
I use it.
I have $3
Emotion.
My youngest in my
are is kind.
I think it bothers her,
but she's more, as long as you talk to
Yeah. And the mothers
who need To,
We got the whole field
usually about three.
I first gotta prepare myself
and honestly, sometimes I don't just kind, I prepare myself
About another minute or two.
And that's the goal. I mean, the goal
to do this bill, and that's part of
Referee Being in school at the same
Time is Quite a
Did they find out?
Oh yeah. That's the sad that n***a
You have to go through.
Okay. Uh,
I'm, I'm digging around here
'cause I've gotta get to a, uh, website.
There it is right there. Okay.
We're gonna be using this one.
Um, that process, simple
structured whatever, um, would improve probably half
of the marriages out there in the world if they
did it on a regular basis.
That's a pretty broad statement
for anybody, but I really believe it.
We just get so caught up in what's normal
and, uh, we deal with what has to be done.
We deal with conflicts that arise,
but so often we're just not checking in kind
of heart to heart like that.
So it's a great discipline to develop and it's biblical.
It's actually part of the biblical commands about
how we're supposed to relate to one another.
But there's lots of things that have gotten me in our way
of doing that naturally.
Usually it is if I opened up
and shared something with someone,
they didn't give me a response that was attuned to
what I'm feeling.
I was saying I was sad. And they said, get happy.
You know, don't let that bother you.
You're making a mountain out of a mobile hill.
All of those responses will tend to shut us down.
And so we have to learn, uh, what to avoid
and, uh, in order to keep it safe for us
to communicate your brain.
Um, my brain all have, uh,
particular kinds of neurons, um, that are set up to try
to read someone else's mind.
They can't do it, but they're trying to.
Does that make sense? They're trying to discern,
are you in a good mood?
Is it okay for me to share?
Will you join me if I'm excited about something?
Will you take part in that?
Or will you have your feelings hurt if I do?
All those kinds of things there, there's wiring up there
that's designed to try to make that work.
But if you get burned, it's only natural that another part
of your brain's gonna say, look out.
Plus don't do that. Plus don't go there. Okay.
So what we wanna do is always create a safe environment
that says, I will listen.
I won't be watching TV out the corner of my eyes.
Sorry guys. If I step on anybody's toes,
but they're my toes as much as anybody's, I'm gonna tune in.
So we talked about the still face video as a kind of visual
for what's, what, what do we see that would kind of show up
as that's, that's evidence of there being such wiring.
Um, what did you notice about that video? Anything?
Do you remember anything about that that kind
of stood out to you?
Just major takeaways from seeing that little girl
and her mom interacting and then the mom going silent.
Remember how it didn't take long
for the little girl to react?
And at first she wasn't bent outta shape, she was just kind
of, Hmm, what's this I talking?
What's the deal? But it didn't take more than two minutes
for her to go from that to kind of having a meltdown.
Distress. Distress. Yeah.
And we said it was properly labeled distress.
Not this 1-year-old doesn't know how
to be in a mature 1-year-old yet it's not about that.
It's all about wiring in the brain that says
we are not secure like we were secure.
The goal is a secure attachment that we protect
and guard and maintain over time.
Whether we're talking about children
or adults, they gotta maintain that secure attachment.
And if I violate
or hurt that secure attachment, then I've gotta work.
If I'm doing the right thing, I've gotta work to try
to restore whatever I have hurt in Joyce and vice versa.
That's, that's why we were looking at that.
That's part of who we are wired by God according
to his system.
One little scientific thing I'm gonna throw in here.
The nervous system. I'm definitely not a medical doctor,
but the nervous system has two pieces basically.
One's called the sympathetic nervous system.
One's called the parasympathetic.
Help me out here if you can, if I need it.
So the sympathetic is the one that fires up
and ramps you up, okay?
It gets your adrenaline flowing.
It might involve your fight or flight mechanism.
And that's part of god's, uh, fearfully
and wonderfully made body that says, if you're threatened,
we've got equipment that doesn't even require you to think
you'll be pumped up with adrenaline
in milliseconds 12 to be exact.
Okay? But what if you
had a big, um, emotional
flood because you thought you were about
to step on a copperhead in your yard
and it turned out to be that stick that fell off of the tree
Just when you first saw it outta the corner of your eye,
you thought, and you actually didn't have
to form a thought before.
If you'd ever seen a copperhead before
or another kind of snake,
your brain would've said close enough.
We're assuming it's a copperhead.
Flood the body with adrenaline and do it quickly
because there's no time to think.
So you might jump before you even figure out why you jumped.
Does that make sense? Now,
that's your sympathetic nervous system doing its job
trying to protect you.
But what if your dad was a copperhead?
Meaning what if he yelled at you every time he talked to you
or something like that?
What if he, uh, just flew off the handle
or all kinds of symptoms like that?
And if you grew up with a whole lot of conditioning like
that, or you got it from kids at school
or whatever it might have been, if you had a lot
of unsafe interactions with people,
then your brain is going to exercise that
triggering of your nervous system
at times when you didn't need it at all.
And that's just putting you through a whole bunch of stress
that you didn't need because that part of the brain
that does that triggering, that gets
that sympathetic nervous system going, it cannot think
that part of the brain doesn't think it just switches on
and off once it switches on.
It takes about 20 or 30 minutes for it to settle down
as long as there's no additional threat.
That's all you ever wanted to know about that.
I'm sure the parasympathetic nervous system
is the one that calms it down.
And that's good because
otherwise you would stay in that state
Until you run out of energy.
Can that be done by a person?
Can it be what Done by a
Person? Can the
parasympathetic nervous system be done by a person?
Mm-Hmm. Uh, she is so good.
Just a great straight person for me.
There's a process called co-regulation
that says we can help.
We can't switch it on and off.
There's no literal switch, but we can help.
And we help by creating a safe environment
And removing, removing your longness.
That would include removing a longness
because in order to create a safe environment, I've got
to at first notice that they're even upset.
Does that make sense? Mm-Hmm.
I've got a, my mirror neurons have to kind of figure out,
oh, that, that look on her face.
She looks like she has got some bad news.
And that could even be causing her parasympathetic
or her sympathetic nervous system to get involved.
It may or may not be a ramp up in that case,
but it's involved.
And if I notice, that can be very helpful if I respond
where she's at and in a gentle, loving way,
honey, I sense that you're upset.
I want you to know I care what's going on.
Help me understand. That's a whole lot better
than if somebody comes to you and says, calm down.
Do you get that? That will not cause that,
that will cause you to suppress
and control your emotions if you can.
But it will not start your nervous system relaxing.
So that's all about removing aloneness, coming alongside,
realizing that when someone gets triggered,
the best they can do to have to, to
not be a problem for you is if they just stuff it.
But that's not gonna be good enough in the long run.
We want to be present with each other, learning how
to be safe for each other.
If you're like us, you will never
succeed a hundred percent of the time.
But you definitely want to get to consistency
because that's what changes the level of reaction
is when I can know nine times outta 10, if not more,
he's going to approach me in a calm manner when I'm not,
when I'm upset.
Okay, tonight we're gonna look at something that's not,
um, limited to just being present with each other.
It's how am I actually gonna start working
on caring for you?
How can I be more specific
and targeted in how to care for Joyce in ways
that may not be what I need?
So she may have things that matter more to her in terms
of relationships than I do.
So I want to be able to understand what are those, so
that I don't go around giving her what I need.
That's how we sometimes do it. Okay?
So we're gonna look at these 10 relational needs tonight.
And they are all part of God's plan for us to live life.
Interdependently not independently.
I can remember growing up thinking again in a home.
I think I've described as very stable, very safe overall,
just not emotionally very connected.
Not doing this kind of empathy and compassion stuff.
Not because they didn't love us, but
because they didn't understand it, didn't know it,
didn't think it would, would help.
So they didn't do that. Okay?
So if we're hurting, we're hurting alone
or we're being told get up and go get busy.
Quit sitting around. Stuff like that when you're hurting.
So as part of God's plan
and um, we talked about the definition
of intimacy last week, we talked about that meaning mutual
deep knowing for the purpose of caring and involvement.
Mutual means both of us.
That means it's happening both ways.
Joyce is coming to know me more deeply.
I'm coming to know her more deeply for the purpose
of caring for each other.
The reason for me to know her more deeply includes so
that I can better care for her when she needs care.
Okay. How do you feel personally
if I were to refer to you as being needy?
Offended? What'd you say? Offended. Yeah.
Offended Angie. Yeah.
Somebody else that's, appreciate that answer by the way.
Weak. Weak. Can you ask the question again? How do you feel?
How would you feel if I referred to you personally as needy?
I just said that this this guy. I know he's needy.
I'd think you're crazy. You'd think I'm crazy.
Mm-Hmm. Okay. Because
I'm not Needy.
Okay, cool.
Anybody else got some good vulnerable answers going on here?
Well, what if I said, I think God says you are.
Now I'm going to mess with you. Right? Okay.
Now you wouldn't argue, no,
I don't think anybody would argue that God made us
needing air, water, food, rest.
Occasionally those things we, we just accept.
Of course we need those things, right?
But I'm saying he didn't have to make you that way.
He just did make you that way.
Um, he could have wired you such
that you didn't have any spiritual needs.
Like You wouldn't need God. You'd be okay.
You could just turn us loose down here and leave us be.
But when it comes to these relational needs,
and if I use that word need be, it usually conveys
as I think Angie, you probably were hearing it through
that lens that says, you're saying, I'm not enough,
but there's something wrong with me.
Someone else said I'm weak.
And I'd say that's a cultural definition
that's very prevalent.
It was the one used in my home growing up
by good people who loved their kids.
There was an a sense that
the only appropriate way to respond
to adversity is to be strong.
I'd say to you, there are so many times when we do need
to respond by being strong to adversity in order to survive
or to overcome an adverse situation.
But if that means I cannot stop And cry
afterwards, have have kind of a release
of the pen up emotion that stressed me out,
I'd say now we've gone too far.
We've violated some scripture that says, oh no, mourn
with those who mourn, cry with those who cry, weep
with those who weep, which implies from God.
It's not wrong to do that.
I'm actually ordering you to do it.
One of the best examples I can think of this as to
how does this kind of blend as we go through life, was
a guy named Charles Thornton down in, uh, Eli, Texas,
where we were on the staff together at a church.
And Charles was an evangelist.
And I mean, he was a really, really, really well equipped
and motivated evangelist.
Just really good at what he did.
Loved people, but he also had a real
heart for sharing the gospel.
And he did that so well trained,
trained us in courses and all that kind of stuff.
Charles was at the, uh, crash of an airliner
that crashed at DFW Airport way back in the eight, uh,
1980s, I believe, early 1980s.
Was that the wind shear? I believe it
was wind shear that caused it.
I I thought you were gonna ask me. I think it was a delta
pilot, uh, delta plant.
I don't remember exactly, but it was a liner
crash, killed a lot of people.
Mm-Hmm. That church was located right next to that airport.
So he, as soon as he heard about it, he hopped in his car
and he was going to go and be a do chaplain kinds
of things, trying to help people.
And he said that, uh,
when all the first responders were there
and we're out there on the tarmac and,
and I'm basically looking for people who, um, don't need me
to physically care for them,
but might, might be shaken and so forth.
He said, I'm just trying to be helpful like that.
And he said it was so intense.
And he said it was so involved there
for, for a couple of hours.
And then they brought the first responders back into a room
at the terminal and fed, fed them sandwiches
and gave them something to drink
and just kind of had a depression de uh, decompression time.
And he said I was just fine
during the two hours of being involved.
But he said, when I sat down and started to eat a sandwich
and drink some water, he said, my knees started to shake.
I had a physical reaction to the stress
that I had just experienced.
Involuntary physical reaction
that is saying we have a certain amount of capacity
to be strong, even in a
highly stressful situation.
Not sure everybody has the same amount of ability,
but we have some ability, some capacity
to compartmentalize stuff.
But you don't wanna live that way your whole life
or you, you miss out on the joy
as well as the pain.
You're actually wired to decompress
and it's best done.
If someone, as Joyce was saying,
could someone help with that?
And I say, yeah, it's called co-regulation.
It's when someone else comes up to you, puts her arm
around you and says, it'll be okay.
Hey, I got this. You're just having a reaction right now.
You're going to be okay. I care about you.
We're gonna take care of you.
Okay, thoughts on that reactions?
Bernie, you feeling better about that? Oh yeah. Okay.
I guess we ask that question a lot when we teach this
because we know a high number of people will have grown up
or maybe even lived much of their life
feeling almost guilty if they're feeling needy.
And we're saying, don't do that to yourself.
It's one thing if you've got somebody who's just always
talking about their issues, that is a different animal.
I mean, that's a different situation.
I'm just talking about. Uh, when you experience a, a tragedy
or even just a normal setback, it is not wrong to feel
frustrated, anxious, worried, whatever.
We just want to give you the tools for.
What do you do with that and
how can you help each other with that?
So co-regulation says, not only am I trying to think
positive thoughts, take my thoughts captive.
They sound like bible verses by the way.
I'm not only trying to do, do some healthy thinking, think
of my options and process things on my own to try
to calm myself down to where I can function well.
But if she comes up and says, I can see you're really,
you're really thinking hard right now.
Is is there anything I can do to help?
That alone helps. Okay.
So we're, we're created for that.
These 10 relational needs are specific ways that God said,
you're going to need these things.
And although you may have been taught
that you shouldn't need them, we're just saying,
if God says you need 'em, you need them.
Okay, how do I know you need 'em?
'cause he's instructing people to give them
without limitation.
He doesn't say, well, just give them to the young kids.
Just comfort the young kids.
No, the scripture doesn't say that.
And it doesn't say, well, you know, the women,
they're the weaker vessels.
You know, they need it.
No, it doesn't distinguish between men
and women on these 10 needs.
Therefore, everybody, regardless of nationality, race,
gender, these are for everybody.
Okay? That everybody has a story about
how were your needs met when you were growing up.
And some of you may have very positive stories about that.
Some of us have kind of a mixed story.
Some needs were met, some needs were not.
But we want to just validate for all of you, embrace
that every human being has needs.
And if you cross their paths in a way
where you have an appropriate opportunity
to hear their story, chances are you'll be able to detect
what some of those needs have been.
Now, when we're married, no one on planet Earth has more
responsibility than me to minister to her needs.
Does that make sense? Nobody,
pastor doesn't have more responsibility than I do
to minister to my wife's needs,
even if he knows a lot more Bible than me.
It's not about that. It's I'm called by virtue of my
choosing to commit to her to this marriage.
That's on my job description from the time I married her.
But hopefully I've gotten better than I was early on.
'cause I'm learned, hopefully she could really
throw me under the bus right there.
Okay? And the same is true for Joyce.
No one has more responsibility to know me deeply
and to care for me effectively.
So what we have found is that we did not even know
what some of these needs would be.
And so I'm gonna go through them briefly.
I'm gonna give you a couple, a few kind
of general things about them.
Sorry, what I, I looked at the clock
and I thought it said six 30
and I said, there is no way I'm that, that far along.
Okay, we're good. We're good.
Um, first thing is, I've already referred
to these relational needs are God ordained
because they're all taken from scripture
where he commands us to meet certain needs for each other.
Secondly, you never outgrow the needs.
You're born with them and you die with them.
You go to a nursing home with older people in it,
and you will see if you walk into that nursing home,
if you got to kind of go into one of those rooms
where there's a lot of people sitting around, uh,
there'll be a lot of people that would really love it if you
just sit down and start
asking 'em questions about themselves.
They have a need for attention. Okay?
Should never have to apologize for that.
Um, thirdly, um, they are
intergenerational, kind of what I just said.
Cross-gender or better way to say
that is gender independent.
Okay? And you go to any country in the world
and these will be relevant
because they're biblically defined, not
psychologically defined.
Okay? So we're gonna start
and go through the list briefly,
but um, for those of you who were at the two day workshop
that we did, I've picked, uh, a couple of these,
uh, three of these videos to use.
And these are on this great commandment network,
which I'm showing you right now.
Any of you can access this and they're free to look at.
But if you go to their homepage, which is where I'm at,
great commandment.net, then click on that left symbol,
what makes good, great relationships,
and then just scroll down a little bit.
And you come to these top 10 relational needs.
And I wanna play a video. 'cause these are
all about one minute long.
And they're excellent definitions of the needs.
They're animated, but that's actually good for a person.
My age seems fun
And I think you're great just the way you
are. Accept it.
I'm so sorry. I just blew that.
I just hit the wrong button and it didn't enlarge it.
Turn it down. Okay.
Uh, where are we?
So this is the first one. The need for acceptance.
I think you're great just the way you are
Now. We do
Nobody's, I think you're great just the way you are.
Acceptance is welcoming another person,
gladly and unconditionally.
It is often experienced when someone focuses on
what is great about another person,
even if they're different
or when someone goes out of their way to care,
especially when another person has failed
or the behavior has been less than perfect.
The opposite of acceptance is rejection.
Rejection is looking down on someone who is different
or trying to change or fix another person.
It happens when love is withheld from a
person 'cause of their mistake.
Acceptance sounds like I love you just the way you are
or you messed up and it's okay.
Or simply, I forgive you.
So start thinking about how you'd like to give
and receive acceptance.
People are different and nobody's perfect.
So who might need the gift of acceptance from you?
So think of a time when you might have needed acceptance.
I'm not gonna ask you to share that.
And while you're doing that, think of
an example in scripture where Jesus
met the need for acceptance for someone.
See what comes to mind.
The woman at the well.
Yeah. Woman at the well. Mm-Hmm.
Why would she need acceptance?
She'd been married how many times? A bunch. Okay.
And that's just one thing mentioned in the
context of that story.
And uh, I'm not a theologian,
but I understand that there were several things
that were kind of related to her.
Even the fact that she was going to a well at the time
of day that she was, that could imply that she was not seen
to be a woman of high reputation.
Okay? So this would not necessarily be someone a rabbi
was going to hang out with.
Does that make sense? And yet Jesus did
serving her need for acceptance.
Can you think of another? Yeah.
The woman that was caught when they were
gonna throw the stones
At her. Yeah. Caught
in adultery. I believe he was married.
I don't know why they didn't bring the guy too, by the way.
But he meets this woman, the Pharisees tried to entrap him
to kind of force his hand in some way,
catch him in some kind of predicament.
So they say, well, scripture says we should stoner.
What do you say? And that's where he
draws in the sand, picks up a or not, doesn't pick up stone.
But he says, okay, um, Bruce is paraphrased first one of you
that has never sinned, uh, go ahead and start throwing.
And the scripture says, one by one they walked away
for no one could pass that test.
Right? Then he turns to the woman
and he says, where are your condemners?
Another translation says, accusers. Where are they?
She's gone. They've gone. And what's he say?
Neither do I condemn me. Go and sin no more.
See, he's not being soft on sin.
Not not Jesus. The what he's doing is he is seeing
beneath her sin to a need that she has
and he's ministering to that need.
One more example that's very relevant here
that we'll touch on again a little bit later.
And that's the story of Zacchaeus.
And Zacchaeus was one of these guys
that was a tax collector,
and yet he was collecting taxes from his own people
and they hated him for it.
And he was known to have ripped, ripped him off,
taken more than he should have, et cetera.
Jesus comes into Jericho
and there are crowds gathering around him.
And he passes by this tree
and he sees Zacchaeus up in the tree and he points him out
and says, Zacchaeus, what's he say?
You come down, come down. You come down from here. Yeah.
Well, many of us learned a song in
Sunday school when we were young.
And the way that hand motion went was,
you come down from here.
Like he's shaking his finger at him.
That's how they taught us to sing it.
And I'm gonna suggest that does not fit the story.
He's not scolding it far from it.
He's saying, s scripture literally says, we must come.
I must come to your house to eat tonight.
So I'm inviting myself over for dinner
And also since he came down with gladness in
His heart. Yeah.
And you do not come down
with gladness in your heart when you've been scolding.
I can promise you that firsthand experience. Okay?
There is another example where we would be
tempted at least to be judgemental
and condemning if we knew
you shouldn't be hanging out with him.
That's what the people were telling him.
You shouldn't be hanging out with him.
He's a liar and a cheat and a thief.
Jesus, not soft on sin, just chooses instead that he's gonna
actually love the man by accepting him.
Romans two, four powerful verse.
It says, God's kindness
produces repentance.
You ever wish somebody would repent?
Well, there's one of the two reasons given in scripture as
to how they repent.
They are moved with God's kindness.
In that case, Zacchaeus experienced
God's kindness through Jesus.
And the scripture says that night he repented
and salvation came to his house, and then he goes back
and even restores people's money to him.
That's transformational change.
And it didn't come about by somebody nagging Z to death.
It came about by somebody carrying enough to see that
beyond his wrong behavior, there is a guy in there
who's dealing with a lot of rejection
and so forth that does not justify
or excuse his stealing from people.
Please don't hear me wrong in that it just says,
if you really knew, 'cause the backstory for this guy,
you'd know, one of the things that is getting in his way
is he doesn't feel accepted
and that's contributing to his stuckness,
if I could put it that way.
So if Jesus did it, I don't have to try to defend it. Right?
Uh, that's acceptance.
Critically important, especially when people have messed up
or fallen short of their own own goals.
Okay? Um,
it's also very important when you're different.
Uh, I think I mentioned in the workshop a time when I went
to another country where I was truly a minority
and the people that were keeping me, I was staying
with them, were treating me just like I'm one of them.
And it helped a lot for me to not feel like an outsider.
Okay, questions on that one?
I'll probably spend less time on the others.
But affection, appropriate physical touch that says,
I care about you, you matter to me,
and I'm not taking from you.
I'm actually giving to you.
So I think I might have mentioned before,
but my father was excellent at giving affection to his kids.
We never worried about my father losing his temper,
getting mad at us, yelling at us or anything like that.
But we loved his hugs.
And I knew I was loved in those moments.
I may not have thought it in my head,
I just knew it's always a good thing with my dad.
That's affection, appreciation.
Think of that as an attaboy, that's a pat on the back
because you've done something good, meaningful,
helpful, appreciated.
Um, So when, um,
when someone like we had some work done at our house,
I probably, one of the positive things I would've mentioned
is they got the toilet fixed.
Yay. You could rejoice with me on that.
But this guy that came
and did the work was just polite, good, helpful,
communicated well, gave us
explanations, all that kind of stuff.
And, uh, and I showed my appreciation
to him in a couple of ways.
One was just to tell him, man,
I appreciate the job you did and so forth.
Um, now he probably would've done the job just as well
if I hadn't engaged with him like that.
But I trust that he appreciated the appreciation
that it meant something to him.
That somebody at least is taking time
and to say my work was valued.
Approval on the other hand, is not so much a pat on the back
for doing something good.
It's a pat on the back for being good, being
of good character, of being special,
Or maybe even just that.
We, we are connected together relationally.
I've got a, I don't know what you call a niece's husband,
what's the word to say how he's related to me?
But I had a niece who was married to this guy
before she died, and Gina actually has met
this relative of mine.
His name's Tony. And, uh, uh,
Tony, uh, was not a blood related member
of the family, but we got to know him
and came to appreciate him.
Not for just what he did, but also just for his character.
And he, he had loved Molly well,
and uh, that's, if I go to him
and just say, I'm so glad you're part of the family,
even though he is no longer married
to her, she's passed away.
But I can still say to Tony, I'm, I'm, you're still part
of the family whether you like it
or not, you still are, you know, we love you.
That's more about approval.
I'm affirming him because I, I like who he is.
Uh, I'm glad we're connected.
If you go to those of you have kids, if you go to one
of your kids and just call out some trait
that you could even see in a very young child, maybe like,
you've got a really caring,
sensitive heart, or how about this one?
You've got a really strong will.
Do you ever think about affirming that one?
It's actually a trait that God wants it
to be used appropriately, but it's a, it's a gift.
So when you look at your spouse
and say, Joyce, I really appreciate that,
especially in these last few years, I've just seen you move
with compassion repeatedly when you hear
about somebody with a needle.
I mean, she did that before,
but it's like she notched it up, ratcheted up a bit.
She's doing that more and more.
That's really more about her character
and her heart that then manifests itself in behavior.
Okay? Does that make sense? Approval attention.
Let's watch that one.
Attention. This is service announcements on attention.
Some people with the top relational need
of attention enjoy being the center of attention.
They're often great storytellers
or the most fun at any party.
Other people may feel especially loved when others just
listen attentively and discover unique things about them.
Like a favorite drink, hobby, or interest.
The opposite of attention is neglect,
which can be communicated through insensitivity.
Not noticing a need
or failing to prioritize someone's preferences.
Attention looks like one-on-one undivided listening in order
to get to know someone else
and their needs attending an important event
or just calling to say, hi, attention sounds like,
tell me about your day.
How did your test go? Or let's
do something fun this weekend.
Your choice. So start thinking about how you'd like to give
and receive attention
because we all like for someone to notice us, treat us
as special and show interest and concern.
So, uh, in a few minutes I'm gonna give you some,
a few minutes to take turns as a couple sharing
one of your more important needs.
So you may not have actually met up your
mind what those are yet.
Uh, I think it's on page 77 in your book
if you have your book with you.
And so I'm just planting that seed
before I finish these other five.
But I just want you to be aware,
we only teach in order to experience.
We want to lead you to experience something.
So one of the things
that can help a relationship is when we have a deeper
understanding of what does really matter to you
and how would you like for me to meet that need for you.
So you, two of you could have the same high need for say,
acceptance or attention,
and yet the way that you want
that need met could be different.
And so it's my job to serve Joyce according to how she wants
that need met and vice versa.
Not me saying, well, I gave you attention,
but it may not have been in a way that really mattered
to her and it would be much better if
I listened to how she wants it.
Does that make sense? So the next one on the list is,
um, is a comfort.
And comfort is the need that we have
to not be alone when we're hurting or grieving
or experiencing a loss.
Now, some of you may be like me that my natural
tendency is I'm a loner.
So sometimes my natural
instinct is when anything is stressful
or a lot to be done, I tend to like to have solitude.
A solitude and aloneness are two separate things.
Solitude is when I choose to be alone
because that actually is helpful to me in some way.
Aloneness is when nobody sees me, nobody gets me,
nobody may understand what I'm going through.
So comfort is when we draw near someone who may be hurting
or sad or lonely or discouraged
or feeling let down or being put down.
And when I come alongside of them
and I give them a safe place to talk, if that's
what they want to do, or at the very least I just say,
I want you to know I care.
That's your baseline.
Minimal expression is I want you to know I care.
Help me understand what you're feeling, okay?
Again, I'm not talking tonight about conflict
between a couple.
As much as I'm talking about other hurts
that land in your doorstep, we will get to conflict
between a couple that's coming later.
This is a building block. It's can I be with you?
Well, when you're hurting, can I do that?
Well tonight, if that's one of your needs,
I'm not asking you to actually comfort them.
I'm asking you to share that. That's a high need.
That makes sense. Okay?
Encouragement is when you have a need to be
urged forward towards something that's important to you.
And especially if you're having trouble accomplishing it.
So if you're a kid trying out for, um, the,
the, uh, swimming team
and you're like,
I don't know if they have a depth chart on the swimming
team, but you're not getting to start.
Okay? So I might want to be at your events,
at your practices if they let that so
that I can even additionally say, I'm I'm, I'm here for you.
And, uh, just want you to do the best you can.
I want it for you, not for me. I want it for you.
That's urging them forward towards the goal.
We know the psychologically encouragement makes a
difference in performance.
It's home field advantage. Think of it that way. Okay?
Um, oftentimes you'll have a couple
where one is high on encouragement
and one is not something they need much.
Uh, that's true in our family.
Joyce is the one that needed very little encouragement.
I need a little lot. The challenge of that is she had
to train herself or retrain herself to watch for my need
because it didn't show up on her radar.
Does that make sense? A certain, the same kind of situation.
She might think, oh, we're at mile 10 on a marathon.
I never ran a marathon in my life.
I'm just using this example. We're at mile 10. No big deal.
We're gonna be good. I'm at mile 10
and I'm thinking, I'm not even halfway.
I I don't know if I'm gonna make this.
I'm starting to think negatively.
Well, she runs alongside of me and says, you can do it.
I'll meet you at the next mile. Marker.
There is something that's helpful about that. Okay?
That's encouragement, respect.
Uh, when George
and I took this test, uh, we, the test on the needs
that gave you a score as to which ones were highest in need
to you, which ones were priorities?
She had a 10 out of a possible 10 on respect.
And I did not have any clue what that meant to her.
The way it's defined in this book
is respect is basically to value someone to defer
to them, uh, with things that matter to them, such
that even going, picking a restaurant, if I wanted
to respect her, I wouldn't choose the restaurant
that I always like to go to.
That would be like not valuing her desires. Okay?
So she comes back with a 10 out of 10
and one of the things you'll do later is say, well,
how do you want me to meet that?
And uh, immediately when I asked her that, she said, well,
if you would consider my opinions.
And I thought maybe I already had been doing that,
but apparently not as much as she wanted.
So as simple as it sounds, write it down,
at least in your head or on your iPad.
Write it down. Ask her her opinions.
That's a target she's given me a clear definition of
that would leave me fitting more respect.
And then don't limit them to
how long they want to make that list.
Just say, I need clarity.
'cause I honestly, I did not know
what that would've meant to her.
I would've been shooting in the dark,
so in a few minutes. But the
Re the reason why that one was so far up there
is because I got so little of that from my mom.
Yeah, there was a history behind that one too. Yeah.
At the time she answered the question, uh, uh,
that was the first time I heard her talk about that part
of her relationship with her mom.
It just had never come up.
And she gave me several examples
of kind of what that looked like.
And it was a no brainer. Yeah.
That, that would probably make anybody feel disrespected.
And so it doesn't have to happen in childhood.
Don't hear me implying that.
It's just that when it does, you're stepping on bruises.
If you're missing the need.
Some people hurt because a need gets kind of
something hurtful is done.
Like I yelled at her or something like that.
But it'd be disrespectful sometimes it's like missing the
need That's hurtful enough.
Neglect. Then security.
Uh, security can be anything from
just talk to me in a tone of voice
that doesn't trigger my anxiety.
You know, uh, intensity
of conversation between Joyce
and me might not mean she's yelling at me.
It may mean it's just she's really serious about something
and it's intense, but that can even trigger me a little bit.
So she learned that
and we actually worked out a signal so that
if she was talking about something
and getting kind of ramped up about it
and it was triggering me, I would raise my hand.
This is what we agreed to. I'd raise my hand.
I wouldn't even have to explain anything.
She would know immediately his threshold for just gotten
broached and she know, knows the story behind that one.
Okay, so that's security, uh, relational security,
financial security, physical security of course,
but relational security just says, are we okay?
Might need some reassuring love.
And then finally, uh, support just lend me a hand.
I'm overwhelmed.
So I'm gonna give you the rest of our time tonight
to actually, uh, share with each other.
Just share one need.
And it doesn't have to be the most important need to you,
maybe it's just, you know, it's in, it's in the ballpark.
But I would encourage you to
give some idea about here's why I think that's important.
It's what's going on now,
or it's maybe what went on for me years ago.
And then what would be one
or two things that would hit that target for you?
What could I as your spouse do that would actually hit
that target for you?
Okay, so go ahead and share with each other. Take turns.
Each of you share a priority need. Okay, you bet
Still triggers me
as acceptance.
Make sense? But this actually at least I like sound.
And then, uh,
This comes from
a my wife
Home and Stay at home.
So it's kind of like me.
I go to work, like I'm gone from it's kind,
poverty, disconnected
Thing as I leave.
But when I come back, this has been tough to kind of reach.
So I think that appreciation piece came in.
When I do come home, it feels like I still continue now.
Like They regular kind program, like,
Like the schedule.
Lot times I
Kind of made changes in what I do
At home just to
Sometimes I just,
How else
on?
I wouldn't say, but it kind
of got little heated.
Um, we just kind of took a break from the conversation.
I don't think we, um,
it was definitely some things that I,
the necessity there.
I just,
I had to do her
ask what I would
be hard.
How did you get to where you could kind of process
and work through
and so, and say she,
and then she would start
all I could figure,
what is your website?
Have you did the videos on, what was it called?
The one I had
command Great commandment.
TI don't, okay. I
Think she got, I just think now
I haven't always been presence.
So it's kind one of those things where I think with our
uniqueness, part of its emotional.
When we first got married,
Um, We both worked.
So, So it was kind of like we both kind of have
the finances and more the business of our,
Uh, So now that she doesn't,
it's kind of difficult, like me to have my work, finances,
finances at home because she's at home when she
does, you know, job
Kids Stuff and it,
It's just A few more transactions she handle that.
And,
Um, We got some stuff to work on the credit,
uh, even though like I do make, you know, most of the money
that goes into the houses just accurate
there possibly.
So some of you will be wrapping up here, which is fine.
Um, just was gonna put this on his
background music, but it's, uh, Jason Mraz.
And we showed this in the two day workshop,
but it was with different video.
I just love this video. But at any rate, I'm just gonna play
that as background since everybody got quiet.
Let just say bottom line of all this stuff about needs
is that God is the source of all the provision
for all of the needs.
He is the source I love because he first loved me.
I just don't love as consistently, of course, as God does.
He's a source. But I am often his chosen delivery assistant.
It's like he doesn't have to have my feet,
my boots on the ground,
but he wants to have my boots on the ground ministering
to her as she ministers to me.
And he gets the glory for that.
But he, he wants us as part of his team.
And so I just want to encourage you with that.
This is a very, very positive piece of the whole journey.
And when we see that it's not a have to,
although sometimes it costs to give, it's not
best to see it as I have to.
It's more of a get to.
But it always helps me to think he's in the driver's seat.
I'm riding shotgun and I got the stuff that, that he needs
because he has loved me first.
Okay? So my encouragement is keep working on
your, uh, on your daily devotional kind of thing
with the Call to Love book.
Just keep chipping away at that.
Um, I was asked about the website,
so I put the website up here on the
board in case you didn't get it earlier.
That's where I was using the definitions.
And uh, if there's anything else that you see that I'm using
as an illustration or something, please feel free to ask me.
We'll share that with anybody.
So, uh, we just want to pass it on.
So let me pause this and, uh, I'll pray for us
and you can stay if you want
or you can head on home in the cold.
Father, thank you for your word.
Thank you for your spirit that does, uh, continue
to work in us, uh, the good work that you began
and help us to just keep getting up
and responding well when we, every time we can.
Um, I thank you for, uh,
loving us first so that we even have capacity for it.
It, and let's be, uh, salt
and light in this world that so needs your love to be
experienced and, uh, put to work.
In Jesus name we pray. Amen. Amen.
Okay, well see you next week.
We're gonna take up the next week.
So this will be week three of your
journey through the book.
Sound good? Yes ma'am. Thank y'all for being here.
Yes, I would've hated to have made a video on my own,
not you.
Good to see you. Take care. Tell your wife for a second.